okay thanks for the introduction and I'm
going to talk about LCS and all of this
is joint work with Marvin kinnaman who
is sitting there so you probably all
know the LCS program by giving two
strings sailor end of length M say and
we want to compute the longest substring
there is the longest swing the substring
of both given strains x and y so for
example if those are the goons drinks
then acad is one subsequence once sets
up string but i mean always mean
subsequence acad is one subsequence of
both the first and the second given
string and it happens to also be the
longest comment subsequence that's why
so the number of four would be the
answer to the LCS problem so in my
version i'm always only concerned with
computing the length of an LCS and then
there are standard techniques to get
from this to compute an actual longest
common subsequence but i'm not going to
talk about this now of course you all
know that there is a natural dynamic
programming solution to compute the
longest common subsequence and it runs
in n square time just by the table that
for for each pair of indices I and J
stores the length of the longest common
subsequence of first I symbols and X and
the first J symbols of Y and this number
can be easily computed from like the
three numbers adjacent to the top left
because you can either i delete the last
symbol and x then you and you go to the
entry i minus 1j or they delete the last
symbol and why then you go to I gem as
one or you can try to match the if'
character in X and the JS character and
why if that works then you gain one and
the length of USGS and you just go to r
minus 1 j minus 1 so that's trivial and
dynamic programming solution and yeah
and someone walk some nice thing about
stable is that monotone path through
this table somehow corresponds to one
way of matching these two strings like
this path for example corresponds to
this way of matching these a CS and DS
and deleting everything in between
now that's not the fastest known
algorithm there so there is a log factor
improvement that's the well-known for
Russians method works for this problem
and gives them n squared x log squared
and algorithm but faster than that
there's nothing known even if you say
restrict your attention to binary
strings alphabet size 2 that's the
fastest known algorithm and now recently
we've come up with conditional lower
bounds for this problem all of them they
start from their strong exponential time
hypothesis which is probably been I also
know but let me repeat anyway so here we
are talking about the case had problems
so you're given a CNF on n variables and
each Clause contains at most K literals
and then the strongest much a strong
exponential time apophysis says that for
no positive constant epsilon you can
solve the case set problem in 2 to the 1
minus epsilon and time for every k and
then Ryan showed a few years ago how you
can get actually conditional lower
bounds for polynomial time problems
based on Seth based on strong exposure
time hypothesis and the prototypical
example is this a fuggin 0 vectors
problem where we're given two sets of
vectors you want to check whether
there's a pair of vectors the orthogonal
and even if there's a binary vectors in
some small dimensions slightly super
logarithmic you cannot solve the problem
faster than n squared essentially so it
takes time into 2-0 of one unless Seth
fails and then only some years ago this
resolve was extended to many more much
more natural and more applicable
problems more practical ones for example
as long as kind of subsequence problem
where it was shown independently by a
mere art West Virginia and Marvin in
myself that also LCS takes time into to
my loved one unless it fails there's
even holds for binary strings okay now I
won't talk much about these these
reductions in this talk so if you're
interested in them and you should look
at the the wonderful bootcamp talk by
Virginia which you can find in this link
or just approach matter to me directly
if you're interested I am so this of
course is not a single result it's
embedded in a series of papers so let me
just cite the ones that are that for
other similarity measures so these
similarity measures called fresh a
distance edit distance thing like time
warping LCS and all of them have simple
quadratic time dynamic programming
solutions and for all of them by now we
can show that they essentially take
rejecting time under the strong ! boxes
okay so what I want to talk about today
is the parameterised version in some
sense of longest common subsequence so
we know that in the worst case LCS takes
quadratic time roughly but what if what
if say one string is much shorter than
the other one so the second string Y has
length m which is much so shorter than n
just the length of a longer of the two
things well then the dynamic programming
solution this just generalizes to an n
times m running time simple and now we
want to prove lower bound for this and
the thief so to to get a systematic
approach i propose to to consider such a
parameter setting so fix some constant
beater between 0 & 1 and consider the
the LCS problem restrict it to strings
where this this n is roughly n to the
beta up to constant factors so bisa
really restricts how m grows with the
input size n and restriction is up to
constant factors and then for each such
parameter setting LCS betta call it we
can ask for is the best run time and
this should be some polynomial with some
some exponent that somehow depends on
beta and in fact it's an easy corollary
of this general theorem that that for
this parameter setting you cannot cannot
be so faster than
in this running time so so Omega n of
course is to be there I mean if we want
to exactly compute a longest common
subsequence we have to completely read
in the host string so the so omega n is
just trivial lower bound and then
there's a lower bound of n to the two
beta i roughly which is the same as m
squared so let me just write it as
easier from and then so i claim that
this is an easy corollary and indeed
this is essentially one line proof just
to fix any input size n fix em to have
the the right the right growth with em
now you take any binary strings of
length at most n minus 1 and Pat and
take a new symbol to and Pat with us new
symbol such that the new street padded
strings have the right length and at em
and of course these new strings x and y
they are in the parameter setting and
computing their longest common
subsequence allows us to infer the
longest common subsequence of the inputs
X prime Y prime because like the LCS of
these twos is something trivial so we
can infer the LCS of X prime Y Prime
from the SES of excellent why so the
hardness of X prime Y prime transfers to
x and y which means and in those were
arbitrary strings of length at most M
minus 1 so this general theorem tells us
this the computing there as CS should
take time m squared so indeed we get an
M Squared lower bound also for this
parameter setting that's it now of
course what is this lower bound birth
it's M Squared it's pretty far away from
this dynamic program upper bound but it
turns out that there actually is an
algorithm that matches this lower bound
so there is an n plus M squared
algorithm a prologue factors it's a
pretty old one due to Hirschbeck and so
we only found out about this algorithm
after proving the lower bound and it
actually shows that LCS differs from
many other similarity measures like fish
a distance and time warping
you've seen our last item they actually
take time n times m for like for all em
in this parameter city now this is all
interesting because it make there's
another lot of knowledge what where the
hardness of LCS comes from but what I
want to point out what to take away is
this is this a systematic way of
studying parameterized problems in some
sense so some sense we are considering
this m as the parameter of the problem
we take these parameter settings where
we you strict how this parameter growth
with the input size and then for each
parameter setting approval about now
things like this have also already been
done like Goodspeed talked about
something similar and here it's really
just a toy example for this approach on
the next slide you will see how are you
can how how it really make sense to use
the systematic approach when there are
many more parameters than just one
because for the longest common
subsequence problems since the 70s many
more pirate parameters have been studied
so we've seen n which is the size of the
longer of the two strings x + m which is
the size of the shorter of the two
strings why and of course the length of
the longest common subsequence itself is
a useful parameter and somehow measures
the complexity of the input the size of
the alphabet over which x and x are
defined could be used for parameter the
number of deletions to neutral strings
something is wrong so I'm if you if you
take your string X and so how many
characters do you have to delete to get
down to the longest comment subsequence
that's exactly n minus L and so big
Delta is the number of deletions in the
longer string small Delta is the number
of deletions in the shorter string and
then so those are very reasonable wrong
parameters and there are some some
parameters would seem a bit more obscure
like the number of match
pairs and this is the the the number
actually it's should be the number of
the set so number of pairs I and J such
that the right character of X in the jet
kart of Y match so for example if you
take all the all the A's and y and all
the ace in X of course they all match
some of them are matching pairs and then
even more obscures the number of
dominant pairs so those are you take
this dynamic programming table if you
have an entry that is larger than
everything to its top left then it's the
domain pair for example this three is
larger than anything in this top left
left supper table and yeah and these
numbers number of matching pairs and
domain pairs they are important because
there are algorithms running in time and
plus the number of matching pairs or n
plus the number of dominating pairs up
to lock factors and there are a bunch of
other algorithms that have different
running times depending on these
parameters and those are actually not
even all of them there's some slower
ones that are ignoring hear them
ignoring us all the lock factors so
there's a bunch of luck factor
improvements also which leaves up with a
complicated situation right um so
there's the input size m there are seven
more parameters that people have looked
at keep them in the upper right corner
so that you reminded what are the
parameters and that there are very many
and there are a bunch of algorithms some
so what to do with this so for example
we can ask for specific right time so
whether there are algorithms with this
morning time so with their be and I'll
go from the time and plus l squared
Sigma or n plus del squared Sigma or n
plus Delta big and bad that's not here
and so at least from the situation that
we start with you cannot really infer
anything about it and I'm taking bets
now where the desert with
exists so maybe somebody that actually
comes from string geology and wants to
take a guess how do we establish someone
finds a solution sir what how do we
solve the bed if no one I finds an
answer and so I know the answer is like
assuming safe here are the answers so
this one exists this one doesn't exist
and this one only exists so many things
and and I'll show you on the next couple
of slides why this is the case so and
particularly I mean we want to answer
all these faucets questions in some way
so let's do the same as we did before
define a parameter setting and construct
heart instances for each parent icity
now we have seven parameters so a
parameter setting defines an exponent
for each of these seven parameters so
for such a vector alpha LCS alpha is
just the longest common subsequence
problems and I restricted to strings
such that well ni always call n the size
of the longer a few strings and then the
parameter m should be roughly into alpha
m and so on so for each parameter we
specify its exponent up to up to
constant factors this is how large the
parameter should be now there is some
problem with this because um for example
it always holds that the longest common
subsequence length is most the length of
the shorter of the two strings surely
you cannot match more than short of the
two strings so if you choose some
parameter so some exponent alpha a
greater than alpha M then this is
contradictory so so and this this
parameter sharing settings should should
not contain any any instances should be
empty well it could be it could be
finite because we still allow this
constant factors like that's definitely
not infinite and if such a parameter
setting is empty or finite then it's
reveals and any algorithm can solve it
in constant time so we can only show
or lower bounds for non-trivial
parameter settings which means that we
first have to understand these such
dependencies of parameters on each other
so look at is so let's look at such
parameter relations they're a bunch of
trivial ones like as I said else at most
M and MS at most M the number of
deletions are at most the number of
their string lengths number of deletions
and shorter string is that most number
of allegiance to the longer string the
dominant pairs are actually subset of
matching pairs so you get inequality of
them and then we assume that every
symbol really appears in both strings
because otherwise it cannot contribute
to the longest common subsequence then
you get that get an inequality off the
of the alphabet size and it also follows
that every symbol in the longest string
also appears in the other string so
every symbol appears in at least one
matching pair so a number of matching
pairs is at least two lengths of
Columbus longer string and they're a
bunch of more like those are less
trivial and those buns but still a lot
of them I just pick one argument and you
can prove these these dependencies but
there are rather many like more than a
dozen and the hard part is not to to
prove these these single inequalities
but the hard part is to make sure that
this list is actually complete because
we can show that for this list of
inequalities whenever you choose target
values or some target value for n ml and
so on and the dist argot value satisfy
the inequalities then you can actually
then we can construct strings x and y
that that that attain this target that i
use up to constant factors so so like
the realized value of n of for x and y
is is up to constant factors the same as
the target value and so on so the list
this list is complete and so this
parameter values so the first of all
they help us to to
them to get a bit of order and to these
known algorithms so for example it's
clear that so we now know the Delta is
at most n no that's a trivial relation
and which means that well this this
dynamic programming algorithm up to up
to lock factors it's actually dominated
by the n plus Delta and algorithm so we
can for the purpose of this talk forget
about the stand program algorithm
similarly D is always at most number of
matching pairs and this one is
dominating and also DS at most LM is
also one of the priority relations of
this one stormy night eight so actually
the best known algorithm today is as
running time n plus the minimum of D
Delta and Delta big data up to log
factors and this also these relations
also help to answer this first question
because D is that most asked red signal
is one of these parameter relations
that's why the n plus D algorithm
actually already shows that such an
algorithm exists first questions
answered okay now we can go back to this
definition of parameter settings and we
said that we specify an exponent for
each of these parameters and restrict to
such instances now we say that such a
parameter setting is not trivial if it
contains infinitely many instances this
actually now holds if and only if these
target values that you get they satisfy
our parameter relations so I'm I mean
we've already argued that if they do not
satisfy the parameter relation then at
least for large enough n that there
cannot be any instances because our list
is complete actually the opposite also
holds like whenever you satisfy the
parameter relations there are instance
we can construct actually instances that
fall into this parameter setting
okay and now we can ask for each
non-trivial parameter setting what is
the best possible wanting wanting to and
here's our theorem that we show the
following lower bound it takes time
Omega n that's again trivial because you
have to read the whole input and then we
have a bunch of terms yeah so I promised
you a bount of the of the type into the
f of alpha but that's really the same
actually I just prefer to write D
instead of into the alpha D just because
it's more readable it's just saying now
you see that the first three of these
terms they actually match the best known
algorithm the fourth one we actually now
have a construction that gets rid of it
so this is more or less and I returned
but in the current right up this this
term is still there so but then we
should get rid of it yeah and now now
this lower bound allows us to answer the
two remaining questions you because um
because um we can write down an explicit
parameter setting so set the exponent of
m big Delta and L 2 3 4 and so on it's
an explicit parameter setting one can
check that it's non-trivial well you
have to check these more than it does
many qualities but they I promise you at
the old and if you if you take this
parameter setting and evaluate this
morning times and actually both of these
running times are near linea well this
year's super strongly superlinear so the
this lower bound actually shows that at
least for some parameter setting these
running times are impossible so they
cannot be such a such albums
good so that's already quite nice and
the binary strings or any constant size
alphabet is important special cases and
so far we we had we obviously the
constant factor slack and all the
parameters so also for the size of the
alphabet we had a constant factors like
so far and because it's an important
special kite we also study the case that
we've really fixed the alphabet to some
size at least two so then we get some
parameter setting that depends on
exponents alpha and some fixed alphabet
Sigma and then and this is just the LCS
problem where we restrict strings really
do have to have alphabet Sigma and all
the other parameters as usual are just a
polynomial dependent on the input size
in some previous card way then we get
actually even more parameter relations
and so for for binary strings there are
two more for ternary strings there and
there's one more parameter relation and
there are also kind of non-trivial so it
is half a page of proof and if you take
these parameter relations and add them
to the list that we had before then
again you get a complete list of
providing parameter relations so again
it makes sense to talk about non trivial
parameter settings those are the ones
that satisfy all these relations so also
for constant alphabet the best known
algorithm is the one that I've claimed
before so cost of a binary strings
there's no better writing time home and
then we show a similar or lower bound to
before like for for any of a bit size
any constant alphabet size at least
three you get the same lower bound but
there was a factor Sigma here before but
Sigma is now constants or Sigma
disappeared but it's basically the same
writing time and we again think that we
can remove this dirt for Sigma equal to
two we get a bunch for more terms and
two of these terms you think that we can
remove the last one is actually very
interesting because we can match it with
an algorithm
so um so the cases where this algorithm
is faster than the known algorithms they
exist them they might be impractical I
don't really know but anyways it's the
first polynomial factor improvement for
any special case of longest common
subsequence since 1990 it's also the
first time where an algorithm works for
binary strings but not for larger ones
so all of the other algorithms that are
known can be generalized to larger
alphabet but here it cannot be done
provably under self and and it's also so
one other reason why it's interesting is
that this one time was somehow predicted
by our lower bounds so we would never
have found this algorithm without having
prudent slob on before and having having
the goal of really finding this running
time and if you want to know more about
this prediction feminine phenomenon that
the lower bound can predict an algorithm
then you should go to Marvin stock
tomorrow and now we can revisit these
two questions here and now actually it
turns out that this Ryan time here is
possible if you restrict to alphabetize
exactly two so what we had on the last
night of course that we had a constant
flector slack in the alphabet size and
then it's not possible but if you
restrict it to average size exactly to
as possible and again like for all other
cases so if the alphabet size is larger
than two here or for any fixed constant
alphabet size here you can ruin write
down explicit parameter settings by the
switch failure song so we're all over
and strava that this is not possible
good now that's it so if you have any
questions so far otherwise I'll talk a
bit about the proofs so now you're just
basically veterans measures have
balanced number of zeros and ones are
and began and measures the whole how bad
is the numbers of ones and zeros are in
some sense
so I don't know what it means my balance
but if you all ones in one and all zeros
on the other then you can have no
matching pairs and if but if you have
all ones in all ones you can have lots
of matching pairs so what is balanced
mean balanced so m is small if like one
string has many ones few zeros and the
other one has many zeros few ones then
the number of matching pairs are small
the imbalance maybe
let's talk about a bit of of the proof
and so as usual this is a lower bound
based on thermal vectors so we take this
afterno vectors problem like with with
some big number of big vectors and one
set and Big B vectors and the other set
you want to know whether there's a pair
of a vector and B vector is orthogonal
and the dimension is something small and
we want to embed this into some
parameter setting and such that the the
string length and on the right hand side
is as small as possible and because we
know that a thuggin of vectors takes
time a times B so you essentially have
to try out every pair of vectors you get
the same bound on the right hand side
and now it depends on what is the
blow-up of the string length were but
what a running time lower bound to get
for example if we set a equal to B and
it happens in your reduction that this
is equal to n to the FM then you get a
lower bound of M squared because a times
B corresponds to n scratch because this
is just theta of N and then you can play
around with this scene we don't have to
take a and B equal and therefore
different kinds of reductions these dis
relation so how this relates to n is
different and then generally there are
many challenges to make this work and so
one is that there are these more than a
dozen parameter relations and in fact
whenever you have any such reduction and
you want to prove that it's correct then
you have to use all the parameter
relations because of you if you proof
mrs. one of these parameter relations
then you cannot make sure that you
actually embed into a non-trivial
parameter setting but you had only known
favored ones are possible like all the
other ones only contain empty or only
contain finitely many
so the proof has to be rather complex
because it has to use these more than a
dozen per amateur relations moreover
mining the this running time has at
least three terms and our lower lower
bounds they might be a few more and this
so this number of terms is more or less
a lower bound on the number of cases
that you have to look at and if you look
at constant alphabet then there are even
more relations so like forever bit size
two three and four we have to have
different constructions because the set
of parametric relations is different and
then generally have to be much more much
more careful if you construct something
with constant alphabet size so so let me
give a bit of detail some for an easy
case at least one of our case
distinctions is that this number of
deletions and the shorter string it's M
minus L so either either Delta or L has
to be theta of em and the easier cases
when Delta as theta of em so in this
case the longest kind of sub sequence
length is more or less unrestricted can
be can be so at least the exponent can
be somewhere between zero and the
exponent of m and the number of
collisions in the larger of the two
strings then actually is already theta
of n that can be derived and in this
case like this running time bound gets
much easier so there's only one term
left because this Delta and big data are
so large there's only one term left
named the number of dominant pairs and
that's that's what makes this case much
easier than the other ones because
there's only one running time bound to
match but still there are like five
degrees of freedom because like for for
Delta and big data we know no the
exponent is fixed but the five remaining
parameters they have they have a free
exponent check up to this program
interpretations
so let me give a bit of a proof sketch
for this and I will additionally require
that the alphabet sizes some
sufficiently large constant so to do the
proof is in this case we more or less
uses black box the the hardness of the
general n squared hardness that was
shown before by Marvin myself so we use
this construction we take some
orthogonal vectors instance and reduce
it to LCS we are they so actually to
binary strings where the length of these
lengths of these strings is roughly then
the number of vectors and the larger of
the two sets and the number of ones in
the second string is somewhat small and
then in this reduction to get the
quadratic time lower bound we actually
set a equal to B and then doing some
some calculations you get in n squared
lower bound we now set instead like a is
the so you take target value of your
longest common subsequence length and
set a or four equal to that take the
target value of the number of dominating
pairs / l said be roughly to that and
then because we because of thermal
vectors takes time a times B and you get
a the product of the two is just a
number of domain pairs so you get the D
lower bound so actually this reduction
already geared strings that are hard to
solve faster than D so it's already
pretty good because that's the wrong
time bomb if you want to show now of
course we have to I mean we want to
construct strings in a certain parameter
setting so so first of all we make you
want to make sure that the strings that
you construct you they don't have two
large parameters and and it's sorry
sault ste d is to to show this but let
me do it for an example so the length of
the longest common subsequence on these
constructed strings x and y is of course
at most the length of these strings let
the length as shown here is a times D
and a is chosen such that it's roughly L
so actually more is the bit this year
holds so we actually have shown that the
realized longest common subsequence the
length is order of the target value
which is fine and you can you can show
it for all these other parameters as
well which is tedious and also not so
easy because there we really use that
this number of ones and why is kind of
small to bound the number of dominant
pairs so it's not a complete black box
this this reduction and we and also uses
let the let you have the alphabet size
is constant and we've shown that x and y
have the right hardness and don't have
two large paratus now we have to make
sure that they have large enough
parameters and to this end we just Pat
them with with stuff that ensures this
so for example we take a fresh symbol to
and weep at with two and two to vm and
we make sure that the length of Y is
like theater of this target value m and
because we have to delete most of these
tools also the number of deletions in NY
and the short strings theta of em and
and well does this make sure that so
this increases some of the parameters of
course we have to make sure that this
doesn't disturb the parameters of x and
y it could be that for example the
domain pairs somehow get smaller or
whatever larger and for this but for
this we can actually just use that
whenever we concatenate strings over
disjoint alphabets then the parameters
just add up like all of these eight
parameters of this night nice form
that they just add up if you concatenate
strings of disjoint alphabets so this
works out and we can't act with more
stuff to like make the string length of
X right make the number of collisions
and X wide the number of matching pairs
right that's one one nice thing that we
add that makes sure that the number of
dominate pairs is correct so this is
some small construction that just
generates many dominant pairs which is a
picture showing that those are just
these strings and all the orange things
are dominant pairs so you can easily
show that they actually have this nice
structure of generating menu domain
pairs and then if you take these these
this complete string then well you can
show that this has the right so all the
parameters are right now so then we
started with something that is not too
large parameters we made a not enough
and and because so the X prime Y prime
are now instances of our parameter
setting and this Hartman's just
transfers so it was hard to compute x
and y faster than d transpose to X prime
Y prime so we indeed show this lower
bound of D to the 1 minus little one ok
so that's a that's like the easiest case
that we do in the paper and I'll did
there is something we used some alphabet
size 6 year if you want to do smaller
alphabet size you have to be much more
careful because these different paddings
they have to share symbols and then
things do interfere and this makes it
more complicated and in fact you also
have to use this additional additional
parameter relations that have shown you
so it's more work also for larger
alphabets of alphabet is polynomially
large and we have to have to use
different construction if they depth the
construction because number of matching
pairs can be smaller and then there are
these other cases of this whole other
branch they didn't talk about where we
use some interesting new gadgets
actually the
this 2 vs. 1 1 vs 1 gadget that seems to
find new applications now and this
pattern matching business and already
finds new applications but unfortunately
I can't really talk about this today so
let me conclude with this so there are
these 7 parameters studied for logs
coming subsequent since the 70s and the
best known running time is this is
showing you there was one special case
will be found in a better algorithm and
because our lower bounds told us to look
for it and for all other cases we claim
that we can we can show that there are
no further polynomial improvements
possible unless set fails and this we
use this framework of which i'm going to
call parametrized find it in complexity
so it's fine go and complexity because
we'd use this conditional lower bounds
for polynomial time problems its
parameters because we have all these
parameters and where you define the
parameter setting then such a parameter
setting is a non-trivial if it if it's
infinite so for this we have to really
find all the parameter relations and
then for each parameter setting we
construct heart instances which since
this is a systematic approach to get
lower bounds for parameter s problems
and and we think that's important it is
an important ingredient for this
emergent field of FP t and p now if you
want to get right our lower bounds and
you have to do either of these three
things we think so either you come up
with new parameters and then of course
our low bones don't say anything anymore
but it's hard to mean it's hard to find
any motivated parameters anymore now you
can of course break Seth or you can try
to get more log factor improvement so
when we maybe even super poly look super
Paulo doc improvements but it's but
actually this this recent work that Amir
is going to talk about tomorrow
the so it can be combined with our
reductions here and it shows that if you
would get super poly log improvements
for any of these special cases you would
actually prove certain Circuit lower
bounds and this you don't not only have
to break Seth but you have to break
something even harder they can make you
some branching program version of seven
and so that's that's it
but it's possible to save importantly
what makes the binary alphabet special
that conference ice cream and you mean
why are there more primitive relation so
there's one hour the only applies for
binary alphabet know about some it
how much room and it somehow says that
like if this number of matching pairs
are smaller than like say the number of
zeros and one string is very large than
the other string is very small and then
if you take them out you get trivial
strings this is something that we use
and which doesn't hold for larger
alphabets because if you take them out
Falacci alphabetic still can have a
complicated problem to welcome so it's
essentially one of the properties to use
you